Michell is with us in Florida a Mitchell
how are you feeling well here you felt
better than I deserve
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
I help thank you sir well I've been
listening for a little while now so I
appreciate everything that you're doing
my question involves I've been recently
trying to get my girlfriend involved
with the program as well and it's going
okay I am about thirty thousand in debt
just shy of that I'm reek about
thirty-five thousand a year on a good
year and I'm trying to figure out here
I've listened to your program every
single day in the car and every time I
hear you say in regards to a girlfriend
scenario you separate your debts so we
have done so we are both going through
Financial Peace University right now but
my question is we cannot be legally
married because she is a military widow
and we would lose a lot of the benefits
of that for the kids colleges income so
my question is is how do we run the baby
steps through Financial Peace University
the military does not pay the children
of a deceased soldier the benefits if
the widow remarries is that what you're
saying
yes they do not so if we were to become
remarried the children lose the college
benefit she would lose a lot of the
Social Security income so massively the
benefits would decrease
she cannot legally marry as a result of
well with what the VA would do all of
her benefits were basically taken away
how old you know our situation I am 28
28 how old is she she is 39
what does she I believe it's around 45 a
year how old are these children one is
at a house he's 21
I have a stepdaughter here in the house
she's 14 and our youngest is 7 okay I'm
sorry
so the lady that you are dating has
three children
apart from you or you have a
seven-year-old with her no sir they're
all my stepchildren they're all your
stepchildren so she has a seven-year-old
a 21 year old and a what a fourteenth
sir okay
the one has already gone through college
and is done and I was all paid for
through the VA and the military benefit
of being a widow and the same would be
done for the 14 and the seven-year-old
the 14 year old are already working on
what she's going to do through college
and like I said me and her going through
financial piece right now so that might
be my game plan for me separately is to
be about debt-free and 18 bucks that is
my goal
okay well I am I mean we work with the
military a lot and we work with the
certainly work with the widows and
widowers of military personnel have lost
their lives in a service of the country
and I this is the first time I've ever
run into this I'm it's illogical to me
now the Social Security part is not that
that would go away but I I'm not sure
you've I really want you to get some
further information on this I I'm not
prepared to argue with you because I
don't know but it just doesn't feel like
the military to me that they take away
the kids college benefits because the
widow remarries now the Social Security
stuff definitely and here's the thing
here's the premise that I start this
whole conversation with though Mitchell
I am NOT going to form my life around
dodging regulations I'm gonna live my
life properly and the regulations fall
where they fall and I'm gonna go and so
if this is the lady of your dreams and
you are the man of her dreams and you're
going to become your stepchildren then
and if we lose some benefits certainly
going to lose Social Security there's no
question about that
I'm gonna work around that and we're
gonna get married
and I'm gonna say for these kids college
and they're gonna you know the other two
are gonna work their way through school
we're gonna get scholarships we're gonna
work on our careers and both of us are
gonna try to make more all of those
kinds of things but but for you to say
I'm you know if you're my little brother
I wouldn't tell you to shack up with her
so you could get the benefits that
sounds like some kind of welfare
recipient program or something you know
I don't get married because I can't get
my check you know I just I'm not that
wasn't what you said you didn't say it
with that tone I got I didn't say that
but I'm saying people out there do that
and I'm not I don't want to be that guy
and I wouldn't want you to be that guy
and so if I'm in your shoes I'm gonna go
in and do a lot more research and a lot
more pushback with a congressman with
some military organizations about this
lady receiving her benefits properly
even if she were to remarry I don't know
about that I'm not positive it just
doesn't doesn't feel right it's not
right if they're doing it but welcome to
some things the military does some
things they don't do well so hopefully
that's not the case but just losing the
Social Security and let's just say that
your all your information is exactly
right I'm still gonna marry her and
we're gonna work the kid college thing
out but I'm not gonna not marry someone
so I can get a bunch of checks it's just
not it's not how my brain works it's not
how my life works it's not how honor and
dignity and that doesn't work you know
you're sidestepping stuff here so it's
no I wouldn't do that so and then that
that's also a bunch of your other issues
like yeah now we can combine our
finances yes we can combine our incomes
just we can you know we've got a $80,000
your income then to work with we can put
a couple kids through school doing that
you make 35 she makes 45 you got 10
years before the seven-year-old gets
there you got five years for the
fourteen-year-old gets there you work
this out and work this out but I'm not
going to go around going I can't
illegally marry her if she can legally
marry her that's not a true statement
but you just don't
except the consequences if you do of the
programs that may or may not be cut off
I really would do want you to go
investigate that though a little bit
further I'm not sure that's right
somebody in the military tweet me or
something or call me or tell me tell me
I'm not crazy here because I don't know
I just I truly don't know the spousal
benefits go away if the spouse remarries
according to two articles already sent
to me on Twitter but not the benefit to
the children so sir either you got some
bad information or I'm getting some bad
information but I've seen two different
articles sent to me Casey and Robert
both sent me one thanks KCK she's
retired military thanks for your service
Casey and the dependents educational
assistance program has no stipulation
about marrying this article says and for
the children now the spouse remarries
spouse loses her benefits that part's
true but out so I go back to my original
statement then I also I'm starting to
wonder if she wants to marry you I'm
that's kind of running through my head
too so you need to check out a bunch of
stuff on this sir